what would Game of Thrones star Emilia
Clarke look like as a scroll one of
Marvel's shape-shifting aliens and why
the heck are we even asking keep
watching for all the answers for many
fans Emilia Clarke will always be known
best as Daenerys Targaryen on HBO's Game
of Thrones but over the years Clark has
been steadily building an impressive and
diverse screen career from her work in
Charming romantic comedies including
last Christmas and me before you to her
performances in sci-fi Blockbusters like
solo a Star Wars story and Terminator
Genesis Clark has proven herself capable
of turning in strong work outside of
Westeros now Clark is set to debut in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe with a
role in the highly anticipated Disney
plus series can we say the name of it or
no
well okay so yeah I'm pretty I'm pretty
sure we can say it's it's it's called
secret Invasion now that she said it we
can it's secret Invasion while her role
in the show is being kept under wraps
for now that hasn't stopped fans from
speculating about who she could be
playing some fans even believe that
Clark may have been cast as one of the
Central skrulls in the Marvel TV series
with that in mind Instagram artists are
Infinity recently shared a piece of
artwork that gives Marvel fans
everywhere an idea of what Clark could
look like as a skrull in secret Invasion
the images actual design does differ a
bit from the skrulls we've seen in
previous MCU films and TV shows in
particular the mcu's skrulls have all up
to this point had bald heads and pointy
ears in addition to the green skin and
purple eyes Clark has in the image so
while there's always a chance Marvel
could choose to introduce some new
skrull designs in secret Invasion fans
should probably prepare themselves for
the likelihood that Clark will look more
like the mcu's other Scrolls that's
assuming of course that Clark is even
playing a skrull in secret Invasion that
assumption has not yet been confirmed by
the actor or anyone else involved in the
show the Disney plus series which is
expected to be an adaptation of the
comic book storyline of the same name
will focus on a conflict that breaks out
between humanity and the skrulls when it
is discovered that members of the
shape-shifting alien race have been
secretly invading Earth and posing as
powerful figures in superheroes in the
hopes of establishing total control over
the planet so it seems somewhat likely
that Clark could be playing a scroll in
secret Invasion given how their
shape-shifting abilities work she
probably wouldn't always be covered in
green makeup if she does very little is
known right now about secret Invasion
Marvel has announced that Samuel L
Jackson Kobe Smulders and Ben Mendelson
will be reprising their MCU roles as
Nick Fury Maria Hill and Talos
respectively and that's all we know for
sure according to IMDb Marvel has
avoided confirming the identities of any
of the other characters in the series as
a result it's still unclear who Clark
and her announced co-stars Olivia
Coleman Kingsley benedir Killian Scott
Carmen e jogo and Christopher McDonald
are playing in the Disney plus series
The only secret Invasion cast member
Marvel fans actually know is playing a
scroll as Ben mendelsohn undoubtedly
other actors will also be playing
members of the shape-shifting alien race
but it's impossible to know right now
which of them have been hired to fill
out the show's squirrel ranks even if
Emilia Clarke isn't playing a skrull in
secret Invasion that doesn't mean fans
won't get to see the actor in a
situation in which a scroll poses as her
character the unique aliens are after
all capable of impersonating anyone
which means fans may very well get to
see certain Scrolls posing as everyone
from Nick Fury and Maria Hill to the
mcu's most powerful Heroes all of which
is to say that when skrills are involved
the possibilities truly are endless tied
my boss up stole his identity I borrowed
his likeness I'm not safe it's a little
like stealing inside
unfortunately Marvel fans will have to
wait a bit longer to find out which
actors in The Secret Invasion cast are
playing Scrolls in the Disney plus
series and which are playing characters
that will probably have the unfortunate
luck of being replaced by skrulls secret
invasion is scheduled to Premiere in
late 2022. check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more Looper
videos about the MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]